[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
politique bonsoir c'est effectivement on
commence avec une news de type politique
pour être un bon politique il faut avoir
des talents d'orateur mais aussi être
rassembleur administrateurs médiateur
réalisateur bi builder a pu monter en
puissance tout en humour notre proviseur
de la république emmanuel macron lui
possède toutes ces qualités et c'est
tant mieux
il a donné des consignes aux jeunes
français qui ont bien compris le message
et c'est encore tant que fait dur c'est
dur d'avoir 20 en 2020
ce sont ceux qui honnêtement vivent un
sacrifice terrible ça va pas changer
grand chose pour nous continuera à faire
la fête dans tous les cas quoi qu'il
arrive des examens annulé on sort
beaucoup du goût de l' angoisse pour les
formations pour nous
pas de cours n'a rien de l' angoisse
pour trouver le premier job
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les télés exactement si certaines
chaînes de télé les femmes sont eux au
point de représenter effectivement sur
bfm télé on les met en avant en leur
donnant des postes clés juste après que
vous ayez appris à parler ça va ça va
très bien habituellement il y avait un
prompteur puis l' abandon voilà
aujourd'hui la plus jeune avec votre
signe votre couteau
je n'ai prétendu ou laissé déraper sur
écoute alors toujours est il que pour
bmc femmes on les met en avant et c'est
tant mieux
dans les jours nets dans des postes
créés au mon dieu que c'est compliqué
cette propre c'est les journalistes de
terrain caniche on n'a rien compris à
démontrer quoi la mesure
quelques minutes effectivement les
restaurateurs commence à s'organiser
c'est le cas d'adel qui est avec moi
vous allez tout prévu ce soir votre tout
en place pour que ce soir on doit tout
le monde a pris ses dispositions
merci beaucoup car unis certains
passants font état de leur opinion
vis-à-vis de cette scène qui tentent de
vous informer le mieux possible et on
prend tout à fait le jeune femme la peau
qui continuent elles bougent pas ces
missions de terrain que dis-je de guerre
à l'est on a tous parlent du dipôle
exactement est ce que vous aimez la
philosophie adeline je n'ai qu'une
philosophie être acceptée comme je suis
basque et tout ce que je reste je vais
la tête bombay london je pense qu'on va
s'amuser pour ce soir nepal
effectivement vous aimez les penseurs du
xviiie siècle
est ce que vous aimez la musique oui
est ce que vous aimez petit nature oui
alors vous allez adorer pratiquement le
afida tonneau chaud donc restez branchés
c'est le afida turner chaud et de baisse
wall comme moi je pense qu'après moi sur
loft 2 et sur m6 n'y a plus rien eu les
influenceurs c'est quoi ce saucisson
mais en vendeur de télé achat vous
pensez que moi je suis dans de tels
achats
jamais de la vie je suis auteur
compositeur chanteuse mon prestige et
mon nom et mon physique n'a pas de prix
ou pensez vraiment que je peux mettre le
nom tourneur arrive ce genre de
balivernes
moi j'ai fait vibrer avec 4 millions j
admire au flower et vous avez 3 4
millions vous foutez de ma gueule c'est
d'être au cri c'est faux pas bronché
pourquoi je n'ai pas encore mon [ __ ]
je jouais tous les fonctionnaires de nom
et voilà c'est notre responsable
géopolitique également de vous le
sachiez voilà un rapport bien sûr
prochainement avec m je sais avec qui
avait finalement solide on a d'un solide
cyril rappelez-vous s'il ce week-end
lorsque nous partagions un panini
savoyat en maillot de bain deux pièces
sur les bords de marne et tous les deux
vous me disiez d'une voix chevrotante
patrick ne trouves tu pas que le monde
est insolite
si c'est ce que je vous dis que oui
série m'avait dit ça ne trouve tout pas
que le monde est un sony et ben je vous
propose c'est lille avec le tour du
monde
les insolites ça c'est du vent
on commence ce tour du monde avec un
nouveau record
un petit pas pour les jours mais un
grand pour l'humanité et on embrasse les
frères bogdanoff bas sur les deux joues
du coup une grosse ambiance au loto de
savalou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et parce qu'on en a bien besoin en ce
moment merci à ce petit être de nous
donner l'espoir qu'un jour on retirera
nos masques pour voir tous nos sourires
[Applaudissements]